. We have a voicemail number.
That number is two
one nine two David P..
You know, the claims about Donald Trump paying
someone to take his essay?
Tees have raised questions about my essay
tease.
Take a listen to this.
David, this is Dave from California.
I have a question.
Mary, Trump said the president has somebody
else take the essay 80s for him, right.
My question is, David.
Did you take your own safety?
Yeah.
Listen, if I paid someone to take my essay
Tee's, I would have come away with a better
score.
It's kind of a sad it's not a sad story, but
just as sort of a story of like being an immigrant
family, because my family came to the United
States when I was five.
My parents never went through the college
admissions process in the U.S..
My mom ultimately went to graduate school
here, but that's a very, very different process.
And that was after that.
That was much later anyway.
And so I didn't know anything about how do
you prepare for the essay tease, S.A.T. prep
materials, S.A.T. prep classes or any of it.
So I had no preparation and I just showed
up and took it and I did fine enough.
I got a 12 90 back when it was out of sixteen
hundred, I believe now it's out of 2400.
But you know, I later learned about other
people who were doing prep classes.
They had tutors.
They took the tests multiple times for me.
I just showed up and took it once and that
was it.
And it was fortunately good enough to get
me into the University of Massachusetts in
Amherst, Massachusetts, even applying for
school.
I had I was just filling out applications.
I didn't understand.
You know, you can request an interview and
this increases your chances of getting in.
There's something called a common application.
I filled out individual applications for every
school.
Even though many of them were on the clock,
I just had no idea.
But in any case, yes, I took my own essay
Ts.
I also took my own GMAT when I took that to
get into grad school.
Nothing.
And again, had I cheated, I would have gotten
myself a better score.
Thank you.
Oh, we have a great bonus show for you today.
We're going to talk about how the U.S. is
reportedly considering banning tick tock and
some other Chinese media.
We will talk about Texas is now ready to resume
executions after delaying some during the
Corona virus pandemic.
And New Jersey will now require outdoor masks,
outdoor masks.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show reminder about next Tuesday, Tuesday
night at 8:00 p.m. Eastern, we will have the
third ever David Pakman show chess tournament.
I will be playing last tournament in June.
We had seven hundred and thirty two players.
I hope to
do better than that this time.
You can sign up now for free for the tournament
at David Pakman dot com slash chess.
We also on the same day we'll be doing a one
day membership special meant to dig us out
of a 300 member hole created earlier this
month.
And you can be notified about this membership
special very simply by getting onto our mailing
list at David Pakman dot com.
You go to David Pakman dot com top right of
the Web site.
You will see a place where you can type in
your e-mail address.
Get on the mailing list.
Tuesday, midday, you will get an email with
a very powerful explosive coupon code that
will get grant you an extraordinary discount
off of a membership.
And then hopefully that night as a new member,
you'll play in our chess tournament again,
which you can register
for it.
David Pakman dot com slash chess.
I will see you in mere moments on today's
bonus show or otherwise tomorrow.